[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Heute gibt es wieder ein Wunschrezept aus dem Team.
Ich habe Siamak gefragt:
"Siamak, was würdest du gerne essen?
Kuchen oder was Süßes oder was Salziges?"
Und dann hat er gesagt,
er hätte mal richtig Lust auf ein Kartoffelgratin.
Siamak und Aline, müsst ihr wissen,
sind mittlerweile Vegetarier.
Also Fleisch kann ich nicht mit verarbeiten.
Veganer sind sie aber noch nicht oder nicht.
Und deswegen gibt es heute ein Kartoffelgratin.
Aber ich würde mal sagen Kartoffelgratin de luxe,
also schon so eine aufgepimpte Version.
Und vor allem finde ich bei Kartoffelgratin immer das Problem:
Sucht mal Kartoffelgratin bei Google zum Beispiel.
Da findet man einfach keine schönen Bilder,
weil es halt, wenn es mit Käse überbacken ist,
schnell unansehnlich aussieht.
Deswegen, habe ich mir gedacht,
machen wir eine schöne Version davon.
Ich stelle mir vor mit so einem Zopfmuster.
Und das werden wir jetzt gleich machen.
Zuerst einmal zeige ich euch hier die Menge.
Ich mache jetzt eine große Menge
für die größte Emailleform, die ich habe.
Die hat 36 cm im Durchmesser.
Und wir sind jetzt auch hier einige und wollen alle mitessen.
Daher die große Version, die große Menge.
Aber, wenn ihr sagt: "Wir sind nur ein Zweipersonenhaushalt,
ich brauche nicht so viel",
dann rechnet die Menge einfach in der App herunter
und dann wird das auch alles angepasst.
Ich verwende jetzt dafür
40 Gramm Butter,
drei rote Zwiebeln,
zwei Knoblauchzehen,
Salz, Pfeffer
und ein bisschen Rosmarin.
Gut, beim Rosmarin, muss ich sagen,
es war ein bisschen eskaliert.
Ich habe Samira gesagt, ich hätte gern einen Zweig Rosmarin.
Und dann kamen sie mit dem.
Dann habe ich gesagt: "Nee, komm, noch ein bisschen."
Bei den Kartoffeln achte ich übrigens immer darauf,
ich kaufe die halt echt vom Bauern,
weil
Kartoffeln aus der Region und vom Bauern
einfach immer leckerer schmecken.
Also ich finde, man sollte da gar nicht zu sehr darauf achten,
ob sie festkochend oder mehlig kochend
– das ist schon auch wichtig wegen der Konsistenz.
Aber ich denke, ihr solltet eher nach Sorten gehen.
Ich habe jetzt hier die Sorte Annabelle, glaube ich.
Die gab es bei uns.
Die hat mir
unser
– ja, wie sage ich jetzt? –
unser Fachmann im türkischen Laden rausgesucht,
der Harun abi.
Der sagt dann immer:
"Ich habe wieder gute Kartoffeln gekriegt. Komm vorbei."
Und dann hole ich die Kartoffeln ab.
Und die sind halt echt gut.
Die habe ich jetzt schon geschält.
Ja, die Zwiebel jetzt einfach fein würfeln.
[Musik]
Hä?
Ich will immer testen, ob das mit Wasser im Mund...
>> MAX: Streck deine Zunge raus.
>> SALLY: Ja. Echt? Zunge raushängen lassen?
>> JOSH: Probierst du das mal?
>> SALLY: Ich komme mir nun ein bisschen dumm vor.
Ich will es echt nicht zugeben,
aber das mit der Zunge klappt tatsächlich.
Zunge raushängen lassen beim Zwiebelschneiden.
Es sieht zwar blöd aus, aber es funktioniert.
Es soll sich jetzt aber bitte keiner bei mir melden,
der meine Zunge abliest.
Es gibt so Zungenableser.
Die lesen dann an der Zunge ab, was mit deinem Körper ist.
>> JOSH: Ach so, okay. Aber nicht deine Zukunft oder so?
>> SALLY: Nee.
Aber so...
>> JOSH: Ach so.
>> SALLY: Keine Ahnung. Es ist sehr seltsam.
Okay. Und jetzt könnt ihr die Butter
in einer Pfanne oder in einem Topf zerlassen
und könnt die Zwiebel- und Knoblauchwürfel darin anbraten.
Ihr könnt auch direkt einen großen Topf nehmen
und könnt dann darin
später auch die Kartoffeln noch dazu geben.
Aber ich mache das jetzt gleich anders.
Ich muss sagen, wenn ich das jetzt privat
ohne Kamera machen würde,
schaue ich ja schon, dass ich immer Geschirr spare.
Und dann würde ich jetzt schon auf die Kenwood zurückgreifen,
weil ich ja da auch drin anbraten kann.
Jetzt mache ich es aber hier,
vor allem, weil ich nicht immer Technik benutzen will,
wenn ihr praktisch das Rezept nachmachen sollt.
Deswegen mache ich das kurz da
und kann auch in der Zwischenzeit
die Kartoffeln nämlich zerkleinern.
Entweder die Kartoffeln jetzt nehmen
und wirklich gleichmäßig dünn schneiden
oder ihr nehmt einen Hobel
oder halt wirklich ein Küchengerät.
Das mache ich jetzt hier kurz
und werde jetzt alle Kartoffeln einmal durchlassen.
[Musik]
Okay, das war jetzt echt schnell.
Ich muss aber sagen, ich bin jetzt doch ganz froh,
dass ich die Zwiebeln darin zubereite.
Denn
dann kann ich es schon parallel machen und Zeit sparen.
Und eigentlich hatte ich jetzt vor
– denn ihr nehmt jetzt praktisch die Flüssigkeiten,
also Sahne, Wasser und Milch.
Und ich muss sagen, ich kenne viele Rezepte,
in denen halt nur Sahne und Milch benutzt wird.
Aber das wird mir dann zu schwer, zu mächtig.
Deswegen nehme ich auch immer Wasser
und werde jetzt das Ganze mit den Kartoffeln vermischen
und kochen zehn Minuten lang,
damit die Kartoffeln schon mal ein bisschen weich werden,
die Stärke austreten kann.
Und dann habe ich später im Backofen
einfach auch eine kürzere Zeit.
Müsst ihr nicht machen, aber ich empfehle es schon.
Und jetzt entweder in einem großen Topf
oder direkt in einer Ofenform,
die auch auf dem Herd eben funktioniert.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es jetzt hier Sinn macht,
weil das ist schon ziemlich viel.
Aber ich
probiere es jetzt mal.
Wenn nicht, fülle ich es in einen Topf um.
[Musik]
Also ich würde jetzt sagen, knapp, aber komm,
zwei Kilo Kartoffeln,
geschältes Gewicht,
und die ganze Flüssigkeit.
Passt.
[Musik]
Gut, die Kartoffeln sind gekocht.
Ich muss fairerweise zugeben,
dass es doch ein bisschen zu viel war für die Maschine.
Also zwei Kilo geschälte Kartoffeln ist schon viel.
Deswegen habe ich es jetzt noch aufgeteilt.
Aber selbst für den Topf war es zu viel.
Ich habe einfach eine Riesenmenge.
Und ich glaube nicht, dass ihr zu Hause
so eine Riesenmenge braucht.
Okay.
Hier gebe ich jetzt schon mal die Zwiebeln rein.
Wie gesagt, ein großes Blech habe ich
mit 36 cm Durchmesser.
Dann kommen jetzt die da rein.
Yummy!
Ein bisschen was muss ich rausnehmen.
Denn die Samira möchte ohne Zwiebeln.
>> SAMIRA: Ohne Rosmarin.
>> SALLY: Und ohne Rosmarin.
So. Passt die Portion für dich?
So?
Okay, es ist eine furchtbar große Menge geworden.
Ich glaube, so normale Haushaltsgröße – die Hälfte?
>> SAMIRA: Ein bisschen weniger als die Hälfte.
>> SALLY: Aber hey, komm.
Ich denke halt hier immer an alle mit
– für alle mit.
Und ich denk halt immer so:
"Komm, die sollen doch alle satt werden."
Okay.
Gewürzt habe ich es auch noch nicht.
Das heißt, jetzt kommen hier
Salz, Pfeffer und Muskatnuss rein.
[Musik]
Ich muss sagen, ich mag Rosmaringeschmack, aber
ich will auch nicht auf die Nadeln beißen.
Und ich glaube, das wollen die wenigsten.
Deswegen lege ich es als Zweig dazu,
lasse es hier im Backofen mit dabei
und fische es dann später einfach raus.
Da habe ich echt immer so
– also ich bin froh, dass ich Rosmarin im Garten habe,
dass ich immer frisch zupfen kann.
Ich habe aber auch immer getrockneten da,
aber der getrocknete, der wird mir echt zu hart oft im Essen.
Und ja, es schmeckt halt doch ein bisschen bitter
beim Draufbeißen.
Deswegen lieber nur das Aroma.
Und als Käse könnt ihr jetzt entweder einen Gouda nehmen
oder einen Emmentaler, was euch besser schmeckt.
Ich nehme jetzt den Kaşar, den Kashkaval-Käse.
Der schmeckt uns nämlich am besten.
Und ich gebe jetzt den Käse drüber
und vermische es dann aber,
weil ich das Ganze nicht mit Käse überbacken will,
sondern den Käse einbacken will.
Der soll sich im ganzen Gratin verteilen.
[Musik]
Jetzt den Rosmarin darin verstecken.
Und dann kommt das Gratin erst mal in den Backofen.
Und, weil ich ja ein Kartoffelgratin de luxe will,
kommt noch ein Zopf drauf.
Und dafür bereite ich jetzt gleich einen Teig vor.
Wenn ihr sagt, Kartoffelgratin reicht so,
dann backt ihn einfach so.
Aber ich will den Siamak schon überraschen,
muss ich sagen.
[Musik]
Für den Teig nehme ich jetzt einfach
mein Basispizzateigrezept aber ohne Hefe,
habe ich mir jetzt gedacht.
Das heißt:
225 Gramm Mehl,
125 Gramm Wasser,
einen halben Teelöffel Salz
und etwas Olivenöl.
Und die Zutaten jetzt ganz einfach mit den Händen
oder mit der Küchenmaschine verkneten.
Einfach so lange, bis der Teig geschmeidig ist
und bis dann
die Kartoffeln im Ofen gar oder fast gar sind.
Dann kann ich nämlich den Teig schön zu einem Zopf formen.
Der kann dann noch ein bisschen ausruhen,
dass er sich besser formen lässt.
Aber ich glaube, Hefe brauche ich da jetzt echt nicht.
Deswegen ein bisschen Öl.
Das reicht schon.
Uh, Chiliöl!
Chiliöl für die Würze.
Okay. Ich hoffe, Siamak verträgt Schärfe.
Aber es war jetzt nicht so viel.
[Musik]
So. Das Gratin ist jetzt gebacken.
Jetzt nehme ich den Rosmarin raus.
Hier.
Und man riecht es schon richtig.
Also es riecht richtig toll.
So. Den Rest wieder schön verstreichen.
Und ich habe ja gesagt de luxe.
Also
kommt da jetzt noch ein schöner Zopf drauf.
So. Deswegen nehme ich jetzt den Teig,
den ich vorbereitet habe,
und rolle ihn ein bisschen aus.
[Musik]
Dann Streifen zuschneiden.
Ich werde die Streifen jetzt aber noch halbieren.
Denn dann ist das Flechten ein bisschen einfacher.
Und dann kann ich hier Zöpfe flechten
und die so drumrum legen.
Vielleicht werde ich sie noch mit Eigelb bestreichen.
Und dann kommt es noch mal in den Backofen
und sieht richtig schön aus.
Also das ist jetzt eher mehr so die Optik.
[Musik]
So. Für den Zopf einfach hier von außen nach innen
diese drei Stränge.
Einmal rechts, einmal links.
Dann unten so einen kleinen Knoten.
Da mache ich dann gleich noch
Blätter drauf.
Die kann ich nämlich ausstechen.
Wer möchte, kann jetzt die Zöpfe direkt hier
mit ein bisschen Eigelb bestreichen.
Dann werden die auch schön goldbraun.
Aus dem restlichen Teig steche ich jetzt noch Blätter aus.
Die bestreiche ich auch und lege sie dann noch so dazu.
Und dann kommt das Kartoffelgratin
noch mal in den Backofen zum Fertiggaren.
Ich nehme jetzt hier einfach diese normalen Ausstecher,
die ich sonst eigentlich immer bei Torten benutze,
bei Motivtorten oft.
Und gerade hier so die Übergänge kaschieren.
Und dann noch so ein paar Blätter in die Mitte ragen lassen.
[Musik]
Und den übrigen Teig werde ich einfach so mitbacken.
Das sind dann
Teigstangen.
Gut. So kommt es in den Backofen.
Gefällt mir gut.
[Musik]
>> SIAMAK: Ich bringe schon die beiden Teller für uns beide.
>> SALLY: Danke!
Also der Simi hat sich ja gewünscht ein Kartoffelgratin
aber ursprünglich mit
>> SIAMAK: Mit so einem Minutensteak.
Aber...
>> SALLY: Minutensteak drunter mit so Lauch
>> SIAMAK: Genau.
>> SALLY: und einer Soße und dann Kartoffeln drauf.
Aber
ihr seid jetzt Vegetarier.
>> SIAMAK: Ah ja, genau, wir sind ja vegetarisch.
Einsatz verpeilt. Ja.
>> SALLY: Deswegen, habe ich gesagt,
gibt es Kartoffelgratin de luxe.
Okay, vergiss das Wort de luxe.
Es gibt Kartoffelgratin.
Es war...
Ich habe mir ja vorgestellt so voll die schönen Kartoffeln,
dann so ein Zopfmuster.
>> SIAMAK: Hm.
>> SALLY: Jetzt ist es leider nicht so schön.
Der Hunger war zu groß
und ich habe mir keine Mühe mehr gegeben.
Aber ich habe mir gedacht, wir essen jetzt trotzdem.
>> SIAMAK: Hm.
Es schmeckt bestimmt.
>> SALLY: Es schmeckt bestimmt.
Aber fotografieren können wir es echt nicht.
Und dann machen wir gleich danach, wenn wir satt sind,
noch mal eine schöne Portion.
>> SIAMAK: Okidoki.
>> SALLY: Okay, es ist echt nicht schön.
>> SIAMAK: Also
ich finde es nicht hässlich.
Also das sieht doch ganz normal aus,
wie ein normaler Kartoffelgratin, oder?
>> SALLY: Ja, das ist das Problem.
Es sieht normal aus.
Aber ich wollte ja de luxe.
Ich wollte ja so dieses Zopfmuster und die Blätter
und so wow.
>> SIAMAK: Was ist denn das für ein Teig? So ein Hefe-
>> SALLY: So ein Pizzateig aber ohne Hefe sozusagen.
>> SIAMAK: Ah.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Aber ich habe mir Mühe beim Zubereiten gegeben
mit geschmorten Zwiebeln und Knoblauch
>> SIAMAK: Oh, lecker!
>> SALLY: und Butter.
Ja.
>> SIAMAK: Ist da auch Mayo drin
oder Crème fraîche oder so?
>> SALLY: Nee, leider.
>> SIAMAK: Das sieht aber so aus.
>> SALLY: Oh, das hätte ich machen soll, gell?
>> SIAMAK: Das sieht aber so aus, als wäre da so
eine Soße oder so.
>> SALLY: Ja, das ist dann halt die Soße mit
Sahne, Milch...
Ja.
>> SIAMAK: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Oder warte.
Du nimmst den Teller.
>> SIAMAK: Okay.
>> SALLY: Der hat noch einen Zopf.
>> SIAMAK: Danke.
>> SALLY: Warte. Lass mich vorkosten.
Wenn es nicht schmeckt, dann...
>> SIAMAK: Ultraheiß bestimmt noch, oder?
>> SALLY: O ja, 800°C.
>> SIAMAK: Ach, das schmeckt bestimmt.
Es riecht schon lecker.
>> SALLY: Heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß, heiß.
Uh!
>> SIAMAK: Heiß?
>> SALLY: Hm.
Ich brauche ein bisschen Salz.
Ich weiß nicht, ob du brauchst.
>> SIAMAK: Ich bin voll empfindlich immer so.
>> SALLY: Hm. Deswegen, warte lieber noch. Warte.
>> SIAMAK: Dann ist der Gaumen verbrannt.
Dann schmeckt man eh nichts mehr.
>> SALLY: Der Josh hat das Kartoffelgratin im Ofen gesehen
und hat gleich mal Döner bestellt.
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SARAH: Für alle.
>> SALLY: So als Beilage,
Döner für alle.
Döner-Salat passt jetzt gut dazu.
>> SIAMAK: Hm.
Oh, lecker!
>> SALLY: Hach!
>> SIAMAK: Ich liebe es einfach.
>> SALLY: Brauchst du Salz?
>> SIAMAK: Nö.
>> SALLY: Oder nicht?
>> SIAMAK: Nö, nö, gar nicht.
Ich liebe es aber einfach.
>> SALLY: Hm.
Kartoffeln.
>> SIAMAK: Vor allem, wenn die so schön durch sind, gell?
Die Kartoffeln.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Die sind echt gut.
>> SIAMAK: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Ja.
Ich mache es
– also wir essen jetzt
und ich mache es gleich noch mal in schön.
Vielleicht habe ich ja noch gute Tipps für euch.
>> SIAMAK: Ich glaube, Kartoffeln sind mein Lieblingsgemüse.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> SIAMAK: Man kann so viel damit machen. Das ist
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> SIAMAK: ultra.
>> SIAMAK: Voll lecker!
>> SALLY: Mmh!
Wer will, kann auch noch Rosmarin drauf machen.
Aber ich finde, Rosmarin schmeckt man gut, gell?
>> SIAMAK: Hm.
Ah, hier habe ich eine Stelle mal.
>> SALLY: Ich finde schon, es kommt ganz gut durch.
>> SIAMAK: Hm.
>> SALLY: Gell?
>> SIAMAK: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> SALLY: Und ich hatte direkt eine Inspiration für mein Buch,
als du gesagt hast, unten drin Fleisch und dann...
Da dachte ich, ich mache so wie so ein Gulasch unten,
>> SIAMAK: Hm.
>> SALLY: dann so Sauerkrautschicht
und dann so Kartoffelschicht obendrauf.
>> SIAMAK: Sauerkraut passt auch so gut dazu.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> SIAMAK: Oh, megalecker!
>> SALLY: Na ja, ich mache jetzt kurz hier nebenher
mal noch die
kleine Menge, nicht mehr zwei Kilo Kartoffeln.
Ich mache jetzt mal eine kleine Menge.
Und dann richte ich es noch mal schön an.
Und wenn es schön wird, rufe ich dich,
damit du siehst, wie ich es auch schön zubereiten kann.
>> SIAMAK: Okay.
Ich finde es auch jetzt voll schön und megalecker.
>> SALLY: Danke!
>> SIAMAK: Man kann es auch voll gut
mit Hackfleisch machen, ist mir eingefallen.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> SIAMAK: Gell?
>> SALLY: Ja, so Hackfleisch unten drin
und dann das obendrauf ist schon lecker.
>> SIAMAK: Ja.
>> SALLY: Und so Champignons.
>> SIAMAK: O ja, stimmt, auch noch.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> SIAMAK: Ich glaube, das mache ich heute Abend
zu Hause auch.
>> SALLY: Ich glaube, wir haben genug,
dass du es mitnehmen kannst.
>> SIAMAK: Oder so.
Danke schön!
>> SALLY: So zwei Kilo Kartoffeln.
>> SIAMAK: Ja.
Danke!
>> SALLY: Ja. Bitte!
Jetzt guckt einmal, wie schön das ist!
Ich habe jetzt Folgendes gemacht:
Ich habe unten das Kartoffelgratin drinnen.
Ich hätte es vorhin
– eigentlich wollte ich es auch so machen,
aber wir hatten alle ziemlich Hunger.
Da habe ich gedacht: "Komm, mach jetzt schnell."
Ich habe dann im Prinzip das Gratin unten rein,
habe dann eine frische Kartoffel
noch mal ganz dünn gehobelt und so drüber gefächert
und jetzt den Zopf drauf.
Und ich finde jetzt mit der Größe,
dadurch, dass ich jetzt eine kleinere Portion habe
– man könnte ja auch...
Okay, das wäre jetzt eine Josh-Portion, muss ich sagen.
Ich hätte jetzt die kleinere Pfanne genommen.
Für mich, muss ich dann sagen, ist es schon schön.
Also das ist jetzt die Portion mit 500 Gramm Kartoffeln,
also eigentlich auch nur ein Viertel
von dem, was es vorher war.
Schon krass, nicht?
>> SARAH: Ich finde, das sieht richtig viel aus.
>> SALLY: Ja, okay, es ist schon viel.
Aber so im Vergleich zu dem vorhin
>> MAX: ist das wenig.
>> SALLY: sieht es sehr wenig aus.
>> JOSH: Das sind 500 Gramm?
>> SALLY: Das sind 500 Gramm Kartoffeln.
>> SARAH: Ein bisschen mehr sogar.
>> SALLY: Ein bisschen mehr sogar.
Weil ich habe
– ah ja, das sind
>> SARAH: 600.
>> SALLY: 600
>> SARAH: 700.
>> SALLY: – 700 Gramm fast.
>> JOSH: Da könnte ich sogar
noch ein bisschen was abgeben.
>> SALLY: 700 Gramm.
Denn ich habe, genau, 500 Gramm Kartoffeln drin
und dann habe ich noch mal eine für zum Fächern.
So. Und jetzt den Teig da drauf.
Und dann noch verschönern und dann ist es perfekt.
Ach, ist das schön!
[Musik]